I think that you are leading a new
movement what the future of business and
Business Leaders
could look like and should look like
that being a human being goes along
simultaneously with commercial success
it's not either or they go together in
fact they're healthier together yeah and
I I just want the best
outcome in my personal life my mental
health and in my business and it's my
belief that high standards are
non-negotiable if you want to be
successful and it's and again why does
success matter I've explained that in
part but I've explained why the success
of the team also keeps people motivated
and in my personal life if I want to be
happy and successful in my personal life
then I also need to be open and I need
to be honest and I need to be a human
being honest with myself first and
foremost